the International is the crown jewel of
Valve's eSports empire and every year
millions of people tune in to watch the
best dota 2 teams in the world
fight over gaben's pocket change the
ambitions are high but the stakes are
even higher and in spite of all of its
prestige all of the attention around it
and the level of responsibility entails
valve left a lot of it in the hands of
well this guy my name is Sir action
slice I'm gonna be your impromptu host
for this series congratulations Siebert
has your look at the right hand reflects
this is licky yeah she's leaky Oh
licky hello Lika yes what's wrong with
this cow oh [ __ ] on me just likes
favorite food really anything I don't
know if you've looked at me but I'll
leave in garbage I don't care but
somehow between the awkwardness the
annoyance and the weird antics so the
action sex has fallen slacks leveraged
his complete disregard for other
people's comfort to collaborate with
valve and help produce the biggest
eSports event on the planet
so why the hell in one of the most
secretive gaming companies in the world
trust their most prized eSports
possession to this screechie bumbling
buffoon now in order to understand just
how bizarre it is that sir action slacks
became valves right hand you need to
understand where this helium-filled
lemur came from well it all started with
some strange sounds coming from Jake
Tanner's bedroom now those guttural
nerdgasm you just heard might sound like
complete nonsense and that's because
they are but four slacks
they actually served a purpose dota 2
could be a very aggressive place for a
new player people don't like it when you
don't know what's going on and I got
flamed religiously when I first started
off like most new players and then I
decided how can you flame somebody who
sounds like an idiot so I used to play
gyrocopter I have like 500 gyrocopter
games and I'm horrible at the hero but
the entire time if you're running around
some like an old confused man nobody
flames you they just laugh about
now what started as a way to diffuse
sweaty pug games and past the time with
friends actually ended up resonating
with a lot of dota fans so much so that
when his computer died his followers not
only raised enough money to replace it
but thousands of dollars more to send
him to TI for to create content TI 4 was
the place where slacks was finally able
to bring his obnoxious brand of online
comedy to the real world and launched
his rampage of appearances throughout
the dota tournament circuit sir axis
likes here in the line filming a bunch
of people who i got no permission to
film and we won't blow out their faces
trying to go home slacks his comedic
approach to interviews and content
helped him stand out in a scene known
for taking itself a little too seriously
how's it going buddy good what are you
doing all the way over there scooch in a
little bit man get coffee you don't want
to touch fear I want to touch fear I
don't want to touch him
why not bro look at him he's beautiful
I'm not dead guy he really grabbed the
community's attention and sometimes the
community grabbed right back there was
one guy every TI he he assaults me he
grabs my ass and he looks at me in the
eyes and I I told several times don't
stop doing this and he does and he has
this big ol smile I tell him bro next
time you grab my ass I'm gonna grab your
ass and that he went for it last time
and then I went for it at the same time
and things got real weird whose parents
is is sending this kid out flying him
out to every ti to grab my ass I don't
know guys
it's 2020 stop honking ass at events
even if it happens to be attached to
slacks
anyway that first brush with TI
greatness led to more and more paid
event gigs but just because he was now
attending in an official capacity
slack's never toned down his wild
personality slacks macho man in three
two one
here we go oh
[Applause]
so after building up recognition as an
on campus analogy for tournaments that
other people ran slacks felt inspired to
start organizing his own and that's how
we ended up with Midas mode the rules
don't really make sense and the mascot
is a sentient yellow sock who's
basically a Bond villain it says hi the
Hat not fight us it's all a big joke but
the fans love it well I mean the feel of
a event and be having a hand and setting
up exactly what that feels like for the
entirety of it is pretty amazing so it
was a natural progression to try to move
up from making just little videos to
kind of experiences and planning kind of
all the content that goes into that
entire event and it's a really cool way
to push forward cuz I feel like if
you're just doing the same thing over
and over again you're just gonna get
into a rut legit eSports teams are
participating in this thing fnatic Team
Liquid and even the mean loving multiple
TI winners AG and slacks was even able
to net himself an extra special guest
[Music]
welcome to midas mode that's right
ladies and gentlemen
slack's was able to convince gaben to
record an introduction to his tiny
little joke tournament meanwhile the man
hasn't shown his face in a csgo manger
for the better part of a decade
Oh daddy daddy why why won't you hug me
but as much as slacks enjoyed running
midas mode he was craving something
bigger he wanted to know what it would
be like to subject the biggest audience
in dota to his cringy ass content and
while reaching out to a notoriously
unresponsive monolith of a company like
valve is the definition of a crapshoot
for most people believe me we've tried
slack's was determined to make it happen
he approached valve with a plan for
producing TI eights content and
shockingly was actually welcomed into
the fold
slack's was given creative license to
figure out how to make me international
and even more entertaining event a lot
of responsibility for our facepalm
inducing soprano tone zero now I'm not
gonna take credit for everything that
happened at TI
it was very much I was like here's my
idea valve was like here's how we
interpret your idea to work we've worked
together and we make this great product
but gaben from [ __ ] day one in bold
letters gave it at us it was all I
wanted it almost died so many times it
was like [ __ ] storyboarded that [ __ ]
I hope right that [ __ ]
we got Gabe in there or we actually
recorded the lines together you've
killed more than two people and less
than four I got I almost cried when I
watched it actually go in it was you
know what it's like the right lines for
Gabe Newell and he [ __ ] reads them
out but it doesn't say slacks really
knocked it out of the park with his
vision forty I ate his content was so
well-received that Valve brought him
back for TI ten which will without a
doubt be colossal it's been pretty
interesting trying to like capture you
know the heart and soul of Ti because
it's a it's an interesting event you
have
to not only make content for people that
love the game he also have to now make
an event about the host country but then
you also have to make the only program
that anyone that doesn't play dota ever
watches because dota 2 was the Wakanda
of eSports nobody knows what the hell's
going on over there but they do snow
that it exists and they have fantastic
technologies you have to make it
entertaining fun and you have to make an
OP cringy which is extremely difficult
for Casey not for me in any way excuse
me but as much as we're agon him and he
rags on himself slacks is deserving of
everybody's respect and admiration
building a career in content creation is
no easy feat but to earn the trust of
gaming's most mysterious and revered
company that speaks volumes about his
character I think the first thing to say
is that he's an incredibly smart man who
acts really stupidly
and and by that that's not a derogatory
remark by the way he's a bundle of fun
and a bundle of energy on screen and in
front of other people and during an
event but he's also lucky behind the
scenes as ways he's a lot of fun to be
around a lot of fun to work with and
usually people like that I don't
necessarily gravitate to them but but
Jake is different everyone loves Jake
everyone is kind of lifted by him his
spirit is so big that he seems to infect
everyone in a positive way and his sense
of humor is incredible and his work
ethic is amazing and I think a lot of
people outside of the industry or on the
fringe of the industry fans in
particular would only ever look at him
as the funny man and not give him the
credit he deserves but in spite of the
tremendous responsibility that now rests
on his shoulders slacks at his core
remains the perfect caretaker for ti
he's the ultimate dota superfan and he's
dedicated to giving back to the
community for as long as he can I think
that got be ever doing this I mean back
in my day he played games it was with
your buddies on your couch there's no
eSports there's nothing and now this is
my life if I was an adult and I went
back and told myself as a kid this is
what was gonna happen I would have
thought that I was about to be kidnapped
because this definitely could not be
true
the rules don't really make sense the
map the rules are not making sense
I guess okay if there's one thing that
people should know about me is that
listen if we're in a pub together and
we're losing that's not that's not the
real me okay everybody's a little angry
everybody's a little toxic on the
Internet all right I'm a good person and
you're a good person too
but if you're you know you're not
landing your stunts I'm gonna give you a
little flavor I'm sorry about this so
know that that I'm not as a horrible
person as you think that I might be if
you ever happen to play with me in a pub
I I swear I swear okay